48 hours of programs about books authors
and the publishing industry
every weekend
here on c-span 2
a people's history of the united states
is howard zinn's best-selling book
this cover says it sold more than 350
000 copies but since this edition sales
have surpassed more than a half million
copies
next mr zinn discusses how he decided to
become a historian and his goals in
writing about america's past
he spoke last november at a cambridge
massachusetts restaurant
hello everyone
welcome
hello hello
at the end of the 20th century we all
talk about the need for community that
is people coming together and getting
close to each other and that's what
we're doing today we're getting closer
together
that's great the cambridge center likes
people to get to know each other and
share their ideas across the table and
we've certainly done that today
thank you for coming i'm jim smith the
executive director of the
cambridge center for adult education
uh the sponsor of this program and and
thank you for coming the center was
founded
60 years ago on the idea that activists
citizens like you and me who get
actively involved in their education are
essential for a healthy democracy and
as we talked with
jim
and john who own fire and ice about
doing this together we that's kicking
off this series we couldn't think of
anyone better than howard zinn to
keynote it and talk about this issue
um
i want to first introduce you to jim
miller one of the co-owners of fire at
ice and our and our host today who uh
and give him a hand for his nice
hospitality
[Applause]
thank you very much for coming i i do
want to say that we are in the midst of
planning a regular uh speaker series um
so we will be getting mailings out to
everyone and hopefully we'll have people
as not that there are many but people
that are as
engaging and intriguing as as howard is
and i i just want to say one word about
howard
and not so much about howard but about
the people's history it isn't simply a
book about history and that's why i
think it has received the response it's
received over many many years of being
reprinted and continues to be selling
many many years after it was written
it's a book about an approach to history
right it's a book about
how history really works and not the
history that we were taught in high
school works it's about how history
isn't a you know some sort of flat
objective reality but history is the
function
um of who's looking at it that that a
war is very different from the
perspective of a winning general than it
is from the losing private or even the
winning private for that matter so i
think
the the book and the facts and the
approach that howard has put together is
is it crucially important not only as it
represents certain facts but as it
represents a way of looking at history
so they may he may well have taken a
whole other set of events and looked at
them in that very same way namely that
the history is written by the winners
usually the mail winners and so that's
why we're very pleased to kind of have a
um
to have howard here today because we
think this really represents a new way
and
not a new way but such a sort of
innovative way of
looking at history we don't the notion
of calling it revisionist history
somehow assumes that it's revising
something that's true so i think that's
a term i'd avoid but anyway do you want
to should i just
um
why don't you go ahead okay anyway
without further ado i'd like to
introduce a close friend a wonderful man
and uh
a great guy
howard
[Applause]
well
um thanks for coming and eating
and
happy to
do something useful for the
cambridge center for adult education
which has
done a lot useful for this community for
a long period of time
i've tried my
best to help
the cambridge center uh
i took uh
introductory italian
three times
and
it deserves a lot of support so i'm i'm
here to talk about history and talk
about it with you
[Music]
so i'll try not to talk too long give
you a chance to
say what you want to say ask what you
want to ask
i guess i
think
does this mic move up
or
do i have to lift the podium
yeah
you want me to hold this
should i hold it
oh okay
is this okay for you
it's okay for you but not for anybody
else
we don't care about these other people
uh how about can you all hear me back
there
no somebody said no somebody said yes
yes
[Laughter]
that's much better yeah that's what my
book in fact is mostly used for
so
bring me one more
is this all right
great yeah
is this okay
yeah can you hear me back there
okay
uh
i got into history
those began
teaching history studying history
uh writing history
not because i was simply interested in
the past
not simply interested in
sort of learning what happened
uh i say this because there's a lot of
discussion about history which
emphasizes sort of learning the facts
about the past and and that's kind of
history in which they they you know
throw a lot of dates and
and facts at kids and then
and they
get very discouraged when they say kids
don't know you know what came first the
homestead act or the civil service act
or
you know who was president in 1840 you
know that kind of history and just
there's a lot of talk even
at the highest of circles as if you
consider the united states senate a high
circle but there are a lot of
there's a lot of talk at the highest of
circles i remember
dole i don't know if you remember dole
but i remembered i remember dole and uh
and i remember dole talking to it when
in his presidential campaign to the
american legion his favorite audience
and and telling them you know kids have
to learn facts facts facts well i i
didn't get into history i was i was gone
into history because i was interested in
the present
and i thought that history could be
important in illuminating the present
i i mean to put it another way i
i got into history with a very sort of
modest
objective uh i wanted to change the
world
and i thought that history might be
useful
uh for that purpose
by the time i
began to study history now i was a
freshman
at nyu at the age of 27.
and so by the time i began studying
history
i already had a number of experiences
behind me which i suppose made me a
little different than
the 18 year old kid who begins to study
history in college
i had
grown up in a working class family i'd
spent three years working in a shipyard
i
enlisted in the air force and became a
bombardier in the united states air
force
i worked knocked around various jobs
and finally i went to
i was married that's why i should
include that shouldn't i it's a one you
know
an experience
and uh married and and uh
by the time i was a freshman at nyu we
had
a daughter and by the time i was a
sophomore we had a son
no this did not continue through you
know junior senior
graduate school you know
no
but
uh
but the point is that by the time i
began to study history i already had
these experiences
which gave me a certain view about
history
that is my
my upbringing my
uh
the family that i grew up in the
neighborhood that i grew up in the
working shipyard made me you might say
class conscious
and uh a phrase that's not used too much
in the united states in europe they're
sort of more accustomed to that but yes
maybe class conscious make me aware you
know that uh we we don't live in a
society which in which we're all one
great happy family
and despite the fact that the
constitution begins we the people of the
united states and constitution was not
made by we the people it was made by a
small number of quite rich white men
uh and didn't represent
uh native americans or black people or
women or or working people i was very
conscious of the fact that we live in a
class society of of rich and poor and
and a lot of people
in between a lot of nervous people in
between
uh so
not knowing which way they're going to
go
and so
so that when i began to study history
because i teach be on the right history
i was very aware
of the fact that uh
that what i was getting in the in the
textbooks
uh
what i was getting in my classes
did not seem to be aware
of
ordinary people of working people i was
learning about the great economic
miracle of the united states that
occurred between
the end of the civil war and world war
one you know when the united states
became this great industrial power and
the steel mills went up and uh
all the coal was produced in the and the
oil refineries and the transcontinental
railroad and and the heroes of
vanderbilt and rockefeller and carnegie
and harriman and hill i remember they
were the heroes and and this was a great
economic miracle and
but when i was studying that it
and or as i say class conscious as i was
and beginning to read on my own because
that's where my real education was
taking place reading on my own that's
what i think where the real education
takes place for most people not sitting
in class but just going to the library
and reading you see and so i was uh i
was aware that there was something very
seriously missing in those accounts of
the economic miracle
of
that what was missing was the people who
worked in carnegie steel mills and
people worked in rockefeller's oil
refineries and the the laborers chinese
immigrants and the irish immigrants who
worked on the transcontinental railroad
and died in large numbers in the heat
and the cold and uh well the girls went
to work in the textile mills of
new england and you know at the age of
12 and died at the age of 25
so that that's
that view of history was a was a was a
very different one my my experience in
war made me
uh very conscious of the fact that
so much of our history was military
history and so much of our history was a
glorification of military victories and
so many of our heroes were military
heroes just as you know the
you know the
statues around the country are the
statues of military heroes you know you
don't find too many statues of anti-war
protesters in city plazas around the
country in fact i remember reece not
long ago in sherwin the uh
there was a
some little
pacifist group tried to set up a statue
of gandhi do you remember that there's a
great outcry my god a statue of gandhi
it's not even in america
we have laws against immigrant statues
you know
really
i was aware coming out of coming out of
a war
myself and having dropped bombs
and coming to the conclusion that war
really didn't solve any any serious
problem
might seem to solve something in the
short run but it never really does in
the long run and in the and in the
meantime it it kills enormous numbers of
people indiscriminately
uh
and uh
so that i brought that consciousness to
my teaching my study of history and my
writing of history
and uh
and then my first teaching job was in a
in atlanta georgia black women's college
spelman college in atlanta georgia and
that gave me a new kind of orientation
about history because when you when you
look at history from from a point of
view of african americans look at
history's point of view black people
things look different the heroes are
different
the the you know the people who
andrew jackson henry jackson had been um
had been a hero in traditional american
history i remember arthur schlesinger jr
wrote this book in the 40s the age of
jackson was jackson was sort of you know
a forerunner of franklin roosevelt a man
of the people a democrat
from a point of view of black people
jackson the slave owner
jackson the racist on the point of
native american people jackson the
killer of indians
uh
different
roosevelt looked different roosevelt the
progressive
hero the you know the
manly very manly
loved war
that's what it means to be manly
apparently
and uh but i'm not you look on any list
of great presidents lists drawn up by
presumably sophisticated people
and that's somewhere always high up on
the list is theodore roosevelt
uh
well i
you know i was becoming very suspicious
of traditional history and traditional
heroes
and so uh there was no
uh surprise to me when i looked deeper
into theodore roosevelt this great
great president who's
you know up there on mount rushmore and
we
hard to do something about that you know
i've tried you know
it's uh it's hard to do something about
mount rushmore
you see and there is there is theodore
roosevelt up there
and uh
theodore roosevelt you know who
when
massacres took place in the philippines
you know you know we waged a war that
another thing another little thing about
our history
a lot of space to the spanish-american
war very little space or no space to the
war in the philippines which followed
the spanish-american war
spanish-american war short splendid war
as they said
war in the philippines long bitter
bloody war a war to conquer the
philippines not to free the filipinos no
even pretense about that as there was
about cuba we're going to free cuba from
spain we didn't of course
but uh yeah
the war in the philippines long bitter
uh of kind of precursor of the of the
vietnam war and in 19 it went on for
years and years and years and in 1906 it
was a massacre by the american army
of uh
morrows the filipinos who lived in one
of the southern islands who were muslims
600 of them they live a very primitive
society they had no modern weapons men
women children
american army just wiped them out every
every one of those 600 men women and
children and
theodore roosevelt sent a letter of
congratulations
to the military commander for this
splendid military victory
which prompted mark twain then to write
a blistering letter
to
theodore roosevelt mark twain was an
anti-imperialist and
although i didn't learn about that in
school
didn't learn a little
there are a lot of
people who were mentioned in school in a
nice way but they didn't tell you about
things that might have been embarrassing
to the establishment you know like they
helen keller we always learned about
helen keller this
noble person who accomplished so much
with all these handicaps they never told
us helen keller was a socialist
that she was a anti-war that she
walked on picket lines that she even
walked on a picket line when they were
picketing a production of a play about
her
that's right the people were on strike
and she wanted to support them
yeah
a thing so
uh yeah i came to study american history
uh
you can see that i was not going to be
an objective historian
you say i didn't i i
knew where i stood i knew where i stood
on issues of class on issues of race on
issues of war and peace
uh and i was not going to be neutral
you know i
some of you know
my memoir uh although you'll never
remember the title
you can't be neutral on a moving train
i
i say you'll never remember because
everybody gets the title wrong
people come up and say i love your
memoir you can't be riding on a train
that
you can't
be training on neutral ground
you can't
but
anyway the
i i i always started my classes off
right from the beginning telling them
you're not going this is not going to be
neutral class
you know i'm not a neutral teacher i
have very strong convictions about the
world they don't have to be your
convictions and after all you're not
coming here as a blank slate you've come
here with many many years
of things that have been told to you and
you will leave here with other things
that have that will be told to you so i
don't care
if while you're with me you are getting
a very strong dose of what i believe in
uh
and because i no matter how strong i am
about my convictions i will never be
able to make up with my um for this
mountain of misinformation and lack of
information that you've been getting all
your life
and uh
i said
you really
well you
you can't be neutral
yeah you can't be
neutral on a moving train
because
and this is what i meant to
say i always have to explain what i mean
to say because obviously the first time
i say it it's not clear
sometimes even my explanations are not
clear for what i meant to say
but what i meant to say was that
um
the world is already going in certain
directions
the world is already moving
the things are happening wars are taking
place
kids are going hungry
and in a world like this already moving
in certain directions to be quote
neutral that's not to take a stand you
know
is to
collaborate with whatever is happening
the word i didn't want to be a
collaborator
uh
with the way things were
and i always wanted to make a connection
between past and present
you know i thought that history was was
important really important the history
was a matter of life and death i don't
want to put it too
dramatically because
a lot of people history is just a bunch
of boring stuff
but no i thought history was a matter of
life and death because
if you don't know any history
you are
a ready victim
of
whatever authority comes along and tells
you something about the world
and you have no way of checking up on it
because you have no no history it's as
if you were born yesterday
uh and so the president gets up before
the microphone and says
uh we've got to bomb in the sudan
well more likely he'll get up from the
magnum says we've already bombed the
sudan
you see
it's a democratic way of consulting the
public
and everybody else
but
or the president
well if you have no history
of presidential explanations for
bombings
uh and then he says well bombing this
would end before we're doing it for
national security reasons we're doing it
before
you know
uh there's a nerve gas plant in the
sudan well
why not yes the president wouldn't lie
to us
no
well if you had some history you would
know
the president wouldn't lie to us
if you know some history you know
presidents lie all the time
have lied all the time we have a long
history of presidential lying especially
about things that go on overseas it's
very hard for the public to check up on
what is happening in sudan just it was
very hard for the public in 1964 to
check up on what was happening in the
gulf of tonkin when the president and
the secretary of state and secretary of
defense get up before the microphone say
well
they've attacked us in the gulf of
tomkin
and zoom
the senate must pass a resolution giving
the president full authority to do
whatever he wants
you know leading to a ten-year war in
southeast asia the deaths of several
million people
if you knew some history when the
president got up before the microphone
and
said things like that you would say wait
stop
let's look into this
and
you know
history
that's what history is for to check up
on what is going on history can't give
you definitive answers about what to do
in the presence and the future but it
can enlarge your view
it can cause you to look for
more information
it can make you skeptical of things that
you hear
so that
well if
if the
both major parties
together say
uh
we mustn't have big government
and in fact if the president
well this is what clinton said in in his
last presidential campaign he said
this is a quote
the era of big government is over
well
if you had some knew some history
you would know how absurd this statement
was
you know first of all as if there were
an era of big government as if we hadn't
had big government
from the very very beginning of this
country i mean that's what the
constitution was about
the constitution was set up to establish
big government to establish a strong
government a government that would do
the work that slaveholders needed to be
done
the government of contr they would
control things that would control things
like shae's rebellion out in western
massachusetts
a government that would
protect people
who were they were moving out west
to take over indian land the government
that would take care of the bondholders
there's a long long continuous line of
governments taking care of bondholders
from the revolutionary period down to
the present day
you'll know that the that
big government has existed in this
country ever since the beginning of the
republic
that government was
big
in handing out enormous free grants of
land to the railroads
in
tariffs to subsidize the
manufacturers
in using the power of the government to
protect employers against labor strikes
to put
people like eugene debs in jail to to
send the army out to take care of of
workers who are on i mean the government
has always been big in defense of the
business interests the corporate
interests of the country it was only in
the 20th century
when for the first time the government
began
under the impact of social movements on
the impact in the early 20th century of
the socialist party in the iww and
and then in the 60s under the impact of
the movements of the 60s when the
government
pressured by these movements began
to
pass reform laws and in the 30s and 60s
social security and unemployment
insurance and subsidized housing and and
then in the 60s medicare
then
when for the first time the government
began doing things for ordinary people
it was people greatly any then the cry
went up big government and a crime not
only from the republican party but a
crime now from the democratic party
which is
shameful so you'd have to know some
history in order to be able to
really
think about what is being said to us
by the
people
in power
and then to go out and look for yourself
for sources of information
that will widen your understanding
and perhaps enable you to then join
together with other citizens
uh because if you don't join together
with other citizens to do something
what's going in the world you can't
certainly depend on the people who are
in power to take care of the injustices
that exist or to make sure that we don't
get into another war
uh
now
looking at my watch to show you that i
really care
uh
and
well
so i i so i've got to write and to teach
from the standpoint of people who i
whose point of view had been i thought
ignored black people and women and
native americans uh
protesters and dissidents you know
and uh yeah some things things looked
different
uh
history looked different when you look
at it not from the top but but from
down below where where most of the
people are and where most of the
problems are
and because i have a i have a lot more
to say but i think
i should stop
and give you a chance
and then
sneak in what else i was going to say
you know in pretending to answer your
questions
so
yes
uh
the president is about to bomb iraq
again
president is about to bomb iraq again
well the word again is important right
because then it suggests that we bombed
iraq before
and if uh
if you were very small and young at that
time or if you your memory has lapsed
which happens a lot you know that you
might forget that we bombed iraq before
and you might
and you might forget
what
how much we accomplished
by bombing iraq before
and uh
but
um
but there again you know knowing some
history
uh
for one thing we'd be bombing iraq
because there's a tyrant in power who is
assembling
uh dangerous weapons right
i mean that's
but
uh
knowing
a little history
you might
think back
and ask yourself are we really this
government's seriously concerned about
iraq because a tyrant is in power
you mean we have always been seriously
concerned about tyrants and power
in fact what is the record of the united
states with regard to tyrants in power
all over the world and the record of the
united states is very clear the record
is that we have supported tyrants in
power in fact we supported saddam
hussein before he became our enemy but
we supported tyrants and power all over
the world in latin america and the
philippines and the middle east
everywhere
you know and so it uh to know that
history is to to begin to suspect
hypocrisy
you know or to you know to say where
i think we we're well we're very
concerned with weapons of mass
destruction
well we
we concerned with weapons of mass
destruction
we the country with the greatest supply
of weapons of mass destruction in the
world
and after all we have used our weapons
of mass destruction
uh
in very terrible terrible ways i mean
i'm not just talking about
the use of
nuclear weapons on hiroshima and
nagasaki and i'm talking about
how we used our weapons of mass
destruction and chemical weapons and all
these weapons in which we with which
we're frightening people as people
deserve to be frightened by these
weapons but they deserve to be
frightened by these weapons whether
they're in a possession of iraq or of
turkey or of syria or of indonesia or of
the united states of all these countries
in the world
and so you you get suspicious and then
you look into the history a little more
and you find that what seems to be
central in the in the concern of the
united states and the middle east is not
the existence of tyrants
i mean we haven't been supporting
democracies in the other arab countries
in the world
but what seems to be central is
oil
and uh and then you go back to world war
ii and you go back to to the the
fact that during world war ii the united
states eases the british
petroleum companies out of the middle
east and moves the american companies
into the middle east and from that point
on oil becomes our main concern
and it's
the nationalization of oil
in iran
leads us to overthrow the government of
iran in 1953
and then so there's a little continuous
line of actions in the middle east based
on our
oil
and it's not even based on on the
question of whether we have oil
because we
we're not going to be deprived of oil
because whoever has the oil has to sell
the oil
see we're not going to be deprived of
oil the question is how much are we
going to have to pay for the oil
and the united states has gone to war
over the price of oil
there actually was one article one day
in the new york times you have to read
the new york times very carefully and
not skip a day
because you might skip the one day in
which somebody told you something
important and truthful and it was one
article in the new york times
in
on the eve of the this last bombing of
iraq the last war against iraq in which
the the writers said
you know this war if we go to war it's
going to be over the price of oil
and
so
yeah we need
a lot of education to be done about uh
the united states the middle east
foreign policy
uh dictatorships and tyrants there's no
question about saddam hussein being evil
and so on it's just that
um
you have to question whether really this
the the posing of evil is
the motive
of a policy which in
pretending to be most concerned about
evil kills huge numbers of people like
we will we've already killed large
numbers of people in iraq we did not
kill saddam hussein we killed ordinary
iraqi citizens you have to remember that
you go to war whatever you do you kill
ordinary people you bomb the other
country you kill ordinary people you
kill victims you don't kill perpetrators
any other
trivial questions
yes yes
uh i recently went to a conference at
plymouth plantation on the wampanoag
indians with both indians and
non-indians scholars
and i'm interested in your
interpretation of the celebration of
columbus day and thanksgiving
we could go through all the holidays
we're
right we're about to tomorrow is
veterans day it used to be armistice day
columbus day thanksgiving well
uh
for thanksgiving
i don't know what to say about
thanksgiving but it's it's you know the
pretense of
there are even thanksgiving stories
written for kids in which they say
uh we invited the indians we you know
our fathers
certainly you know my one of my
ancestors i know
uh
invited the indians
uh to
a feast which the indians were not
accustomed to you see
uh and
and this was an actual history book for
kids
and and
and gave them things they'd never heard
of you know like corn you know
potatoes you know
well
yeah thanksgiving you know the whole
business of thanksgiving and which hides
the you know the simple fact that we
uh came over here granted you know uh
those people you know had various
reasons for leaving but the fact is they
took over the land that these people
lived on and when these people resisted
they massacred them bringing massacres
in return i don't want to you know deny
massacres took place on both sides but
but underlying the massacres on both
sides was the fact is they were living
on this land with their own kind of
civilization and
and our ancestors
drove them out and annihilated them when
they resisted
now talk about what's missing in the
history books
the only thing i learned about our
indian history
when i went to school was
yeah the pilgrims and thanksgiving and
john smith and pocahontas
and uh
custer's last stand
you know the few things that that's it
i did not learn in in
uh
you know and i i
i went all the way up if you can
consider that all the way up to a phd in
history and uh but i really didn't learn
about the fact that we had waged
countless wars against the indians in
the course of
taking over this country the maps on our
school in our school rooms high school
school rooms were
uh westwood expansion
it was expansion it was like a
biological thing you just expanded
and then tell you what was the cost the
human cost of this expansion you it was
a louisiana purchase everything was neat
it was a just a
a nice bargain commercial transaction
it was 15 million dollars for this
enormous territory doubling the size of
the country
and it's wet and it's
vacant
you can tell because you look at the map
and it's huge it says louisiana purchase
and it's vacant
very very large numbers of
indians lived in this territory in order
for that territory to comply the united
states they had to be annihilated
uh
anyway i'm i'm sorry you talked about
thanksgiving drove me to this but
columbus
the columbus story well
uh
we always refer people to our books
right
yeah we don't want to give it all away
well actually you don't even have to buy
my book you just have to like pick it up
browse in it read the first 10 pages and
it'll tell you things about columbus
that
the nice but the the nice part of it
there's a nice part of the story and
that is this
that the that the telling of the
columbus story has changed
over the past
i don't know 10 15 years
uh
that for the first time that original
glory story of columbus the adventurer
columbus the brave man columbus the
great navigator columbus the religious
man
uh that that uh
totally heroic story of columbus
that has
given way not totally of course but at
least partially
in in thousands of classrooms around the
country now the story of columbus is
taught in a different way
in fact i just
got in the mail a copy of a
outfit outfit in milwaukee called
rethinking schools
a wonderful outfit who
uh they have contacts with teachers all
over the country
and the great resource for teachers who
want to know what where to get good
books for kids and so on and
in
they just put out a revised edition of
what in
the quincentennial year 1992 was for
them a best seller a 100
page of sort of booklet on columbus
called rethinking columbus
which immediately sold 200 000 copies
and now they put in a new edition with
rich material so you know there's
there's hope for a revision of the
columbus
story
yes
yes speaking of revision um you know
there was all that hubbub about
jefferson and sally hemmings and one of
the things that i heard on npr was that
you know certainly there have been
academics and in fact african-american
and female academics who have talked
about the sally hemings relationship
with jefferson and the fact that they'd
had a child at least one together before
but that people didn't seem to take that
quite as seriously um
i'm wondering from your perspective as a
a white male who's in the academic world
are there things that you've done to
change that kind of because academia is
certainly one of the last bastions
probably of white male
power power structure
academia as a bastion of white male
power
really
by the way
i am not in academia anymore
uh
i
happily left
some years ago i i no longer teach but
um
the
the asking what i have done i mean what
i have what's your view on it and what
have you done
well
i haven't done anything specifically on
that particular right not that you know
but i mean the main point is
that
the slavery was not just
uh
sort of
embarrassing blip
uh in american history and very often
that you know it's passed over that way
it's sort of very interesting here we
have
well you know how we're inundated with
with uh
self-congratulation about our country
and our democracy and etc etc
and uh
when you think that we had
slavery for over 200 years
we had helped black slaves in this
country of over 200 years
that you can't simply talk about our
history uh as if it's been a glorious
democratic country with but there was
this little problem
of slavery
which we
took care of
you see of course we never did take care
of it we still haven't really taken care
of the legacy of slavery but i think
it's very the story of jefferson henry
this
sally henry is very important simply
because
it
sort of makes people think about
not just slavery is an abstraction but
slavery has a reality for
black people especially for black women
for slave women
and that whole that whole issue of the
uh
the
how
slavery bad enough is in itself was
doubly bad or triply bad for slave women
in what they had to endure
and uh
and that this endurance took place at
the hands of one of the
founding fathers doesn't
only sort of emphasize the fact that
uh this was part of the national
heritage
and i think and
those of us who have tried to write
about slavery in a fuller way and
and bring it down to human terms and
make people understand what slaves went
through was very
almost impossible thing to do
but
one of the ways in which you do that is
is i think to bring forth the personal
stories
of what especially what slave women
endured
uh
and
the jefferson's
sally hamming story is sort of a way of
of uh emphasizing that yeah one of my
questions was about the legitimacy of
the speaker that because you are a white
man perhaps not you necessarily but a
lot of white
male academics that their voice is going
to get heard and so if you're going to
expose the issue of of the intermarriage
or the rape of slave women that somehow
that that gets a little bit more
legitimacy than if it's an
african-american woman oh she's got that
same thing she's always harping on
i'm wondering if you have a thought
about it well i do have a thought about
this yeah
if i didn't have a thought about it
you've given me a thought about it you
see but um
yeah it's uh
it's sad you see
that people will take uh you know the
the message better
from somebody that they identify with
that rather than from
the oppressed group itself
you know and but you know and uh
and this has been this has been true for
a long time
um but i think
uh
and here again every once in a while i
come up with an encouraging bit of
information just you know to lessen the
number of suicides of people who walk
out of the room that i'm in
and
the
uh and the encouraging thing is that we
now have a whole new generation of
african-american historians
of
men women we in fact have a whole new
generation of native american historians
who uh and native american studies
departments and and
so that
more and more it is possible whereas at
one time yes a lot of this
came from white academics because there
weren't that many black academics around
you know but uh more and more we're
getting to hear the story from um
people
african-american men
women
but i think we all you know we all have
a responsibility in our own way to do
what we can
you had yes that you were
anti-war
and i was wondering what you thought of
the oppressed rising up against their
oppressors and more specifically what
you think of like the
fsln and the gorillas up in guatemala
well that's one of the toughest
questions
i hate tough questions
no it's no it's an important question
the
uh
it's very hard i am anti-war
um because i believe that
war you know by
definition
is the
indiscriminate
killing of large numbers of people
for us
even if a social purpose is proclaimed
the social purpose is distant
and the killing is immediate
and so
that even in a revolutionary situation
uh as sympathetic as you are to the
revolutionists
you have to face the fact that
uh
revolutions when they become
murderous
you know
lose a focus
they begin to get indiscriminate
and in fact this happened in el salvador
where a lot of even the
the you know the guerrilla revolutionary
movement in el salvador began
doing things to ordinary peasants you
know
and
and things get uh
and so ugly things are done
for an end which either is then not
achieved or if it is achieved
begins to turn sour and one of the
reasons it begins to turn sour i think
is because the revolutions have been
corrupted in the process
uh by what becomes an addiction to
violence
and so i think the great intellectual
challenge of our time the great
political challenge great human
challenge of our time
is how to achieve social justice how to
bring about yes revolutionary change
without massive violence
and i think of i think of
south africa
and i think of the fact that
the african national congress could have
decided
on
armed struggle
in a large-scale way that is a bloody
civil war to end apartheid in south
africa
and probably would have won and
apartheid would have been ended
maybe a million people would have been
killed most of them black probably
but apartheid would have been ended
and i think the african national
congress at a certain point made a
decision
that
that kind of armed revolutionary
struggle
on that scale
uh
would not be a good thing for the black
people of south africa that instead they
would
certainly not submit certainly not be
passive but they would engage in a
different kind of warfare
that is a
kind of
guerrilla warfare perhaps kind of
a wearing down of the enemy a use of
many different tactics of strikes or
boycotts some acts of violence yes
bringing of international pressure
economic pressure uh sanctions
now that
takes longer to solve a problem than war
see the thing that's seductive about war
is it's a quick solution
but it's a quick solution which doesn't
solve basic problems
and
a protracted struggle against injustice
without a massive violence requires
a
longer period of time
requires a lot of risk and sacrifice and
pain and suffering in the meantime in a
way that the
people of south africa have suffered in
all these years
that they uh under apartheid
but uh
they did it
i mean not that they've solved all their
problems obviously and not a huge
problem still running but apartheid as
that institution is gone and without
that massive civil war and so uh you
know i think
those people
are on
who
welcomed you know
revolutions revolutionary movements
guerrilla movements in various parts of
the world where ugly dictatorships were
in power
need to rethink
the that question
of tactics but as well you'll see in el
salvador after all these years they
finally
had to come to a
political solution
and
which is not really a solution
which may just postpone
you know postpone the day of of justice
in el salvador but
uh
and a lot of people were being killed
and they weren't getting anywhere
so
yeah that's an important question yes i
think we're going to take just one more
question and then we've got to let you
sign books on those people okay
in political action the second world war
what would have prevented the second
world what would prevent a second world
war
i thought i had tough questions up to
now
in one minute
[Laughter]
aside what might have been done early on
against hitler but i would say a war in
which 50 million people are killed and
at the end of it you get rid of
a few specific manifestations of fascism
but leave a world of fascisms and
militarism and imperialism still intact
all over the world and leaving two
superpowers with with enormous weapons
of mass destruction uh
is not something to be cherished as a
right way to get rid of fascism what
would have taken
resistance
uh
uh guerilla warfare
uh
focused acts uh i mean there was
resistance in norway there was
resistance in denmark there were there
were
during world war ii there's specific
acts of resistance in certain places
there's a kind of resistance which even
the most powerful military machine
cannot deal with
if they can deal with massive
uh military maneuvers but they can't
easily deal with strikes with boycotts
with the resistance of an entire
population takes longer time
it's it's very hard to go back over the
world what you always have to go back
over a past event a past event
has the look of of being inevitable once
it's happened and so the way uh fascism
was ended in europe has the look of
inevitability as if there were no other
possible way to deal with fascism and we
would need to
uh use an enormous amount of imagination
to try to figure out how it could have
been done without 50 million lives being
lost and without leaving a world
as it was left after world war ii
yes
[Applause]
thank you very much we'd like to get
howard up to the
here where he'll sign some books
hopefully and say hello to you and maybe
answer a few questions as he's doing
that so if we can let
howard out and then say hello to him on
the way out thank you so much thank you
okay
will you bring it up to the lunch break
up to the table so you get there and
she'll pick it up there why don't you go
right up there
[Music]